novel structure versus screenplay
structure how are they different how are
they the same I mean I think that
there's a lot of similarities between
them and when I teach writing I tend to
actually reference screenplay structure
the difference would be that screenplays
are much more rigid in terms of the
first act which is usually the first 30
pages or show so second act midpoint and
and then how long a script can be like
it is much more rigid in terms of the
way they're structured where is it the
book you have more leeway the word count
can vary the page count can vary and
then exactly when you're hitting these
big moments can also vary novels can
also get away with being more episodic
which is to say you know one thing
happens one thing happens one thing
happens it's not always building whereas
in a film you can't really do that or if
you do I think your a lot of times in
trouble because it's not really building
into something that's a climax I mean
most films you're looking at 90 minutes
to hours really at the most I mean I
know some films go longer but usually it
doesn't work out well so I think you
just have a lot more leeway but that
said I really believe that that books
benefit from having a lot of the same
things in place so instead of like into
first act moment I would call it like
the big thing that happens right away or
the inciting incident of a book so that
would really kind of be the end of first
act in a screenplay so we use a little
bit of a different terminology in terms
of what I would call it but yeah like I
said I think with novels you can be a
little more flexible but I tend to think
that having the same things climax
you know moral choice of the character
and then after the climax resolution I
mean those things are all the same for
the most part I mean stories are told a
certain way for a reason